mit paradise home for children also miss
perry ginsheim für merkwürdige kinder
auf deutsch fantasievoller weise die
insel der besonderen kinder ist der neue
film von tim burton
das ist eine verfilmung der bücher von
hendrix also vor allem des ersten buches
das auch so heißt wie der film
eigentlich heißt und das sind bücher
sehr schöne kinder und jugendbücher oder
jugend und jugendbücher und es geht um
eine art waisenhaus schule in den
menschen untergebracht um die noch klein
sind aber dafür zum beispiel hinten
zähne haben am kopf oder unsichtbar sind
wo der sehr schnell pflanzen zum wachsen
bringen können oder schweben das heißt
es ist eine mischung aus harry potter
ex-mann und geisterbahn von heiner
müller
in dem film ist einiges von buch wobei
es wahrscheinlich so gelaufen ist dass
jemand das ding ausgedruckt hat auf
papier und dem burtons dann ein paar mal
durcheinander geschmissen hat und das
was dann so am boden landete wurde dann
irgendwie der film also wenn man die
bücher jetzt sehr sehr doll lieb das
heißt so liebt wie sagen wir mal leute
die an heilige schriften glauben ihre
heiligen schriften lieben sollte man
sich darauf gefasst machen dass ein paar
sachen geändert vertauscht von innen
nach außen gekrempelt auf den kopf
gestellt und überhaupt thematisiert sind
einsehen dass du einen sagen hat diese
radler schützen wo die anderen treffen
uns am eingang der stadt
tim burton versteht sich und das sieht
man auch in diesem film wieder als so
eine art nachfolger von etwas was er für
journalismus hält also so die linie von
buñuels frank meyer seltsame komische
filme david lynch und so weiter und das
lustig ist dass er sich da selber
missversteht denn er ist einfach nur
sehr sehr böse sehr ungezogener steven
spielberg und das darf in diesem film
sein das heißt dieser kunst quatsch da
draußen weil das ist einfach nicht sein
ding da ist also obere mittelklasse aber
in tim burtons super werden ist ja eine
richtige regisseur für ein shooting
burton film aber er verwechselt immer
alle anderen songs mit diesem genre und
insofern muss man halt machen lassen
manchmal geht es in die hose manchmal
nicht und wenn man pech hat kommt halt
wieder johnny depp als springteufel an
seinen fehlern die er irgendwie im
hintern eingebaut hat aus dem kasten
gesprungen diesmal aber hat die
twentieth century fox offenbar
vertraglich sondern der verdient
verbieten lassen stattdessen es eva
green drin judi dench ist drin lauter
leute die wissen was sie tun also
butterfield und es ist ein sehr schöner
und sehr guter film geworden entweder
trotz oder wegen oder wahrscheinlich
beides tim burton